a new lexical scope is created every
time you type out a function definition
the function definition spans from the
letter F all the way down to this end
curly brace the two curly braces around
the functions body and close the area of
the code where different access rules
will apply let's color in all the area
between these braces to represent the
region that will have new rules and that
we would thus consider a different
lexical scope once you've made a new
lexical scope by defining a function it
has a few more limits than the lexical
scope around it although you can still
access variables from the broader
lexical scope containing that inner
lexical scope and you can access
variables that get defined inside that
inner scope the variables you define
inside the inner scope cannot be
referred to from outside that scope
outside these curly braces referring to
a variable that was local to the inner
scope will result in an error so what
variables do you think would be
available from within the body of a new
saga function that is to say what
variables could you access in between
these two curly braces